serial killers Gorgon anatomy and one
very animated disembodied hand Tim
Burton's Wednesday is the perfect family
show attempted murder would that have
looked on your record terrible everyone
would know I failed to get the job done
Netflix gave Wednesday an 8 episode
season order back in February of 2021
officially getting the ball rolling on
the project Tim Burton signed on to
direct and executive produce while Al
gaw and Miles Miller also serve as
co-showrunners production ran from
September 2021 to March 2022 so when do
we expect to see it on September 23rd
Netflix announced the series would drop
November 23rd and revealed a brand new
poster Wednesday stands poised twirling
an umbrella outside what is likely
Nevermore Academy towering in the
background as show star Jenna Ortega has
stated her version of Wednesday Adams
has something hidden away just below the
surface while the series will miss the
Halloween season Wednesday does arrive
just in time for Thanksgiving and
quality time with the family nothing
like good old-fashioned murder to bring
folks together
Netflix is Wednesday boasts quite the
Stacked cast from top to bottom as far
as the atoms themselves go Jenna Ortega
plays Wednesday Catherine Zeta Jones
portrays her mother Morticia and Louise
Guzman joins them as family patriarch
Gomez Isaac Ordonez takes on Wednesday's
brother Pugsley George purcella plays
Lurch the Butler and Victor dorobantu or
his hand at least will appear as thing
outside of The Adams Family unit viewers
will get to see a host of incredible
actors the extended cast of Wednesday
includes Gwendolyn Christie as Larissa
Weems Jamie McShane as Sheriff Donovan
Galpin Joy Sunday as Bianca Barclay Emma
Myers is Enid Sinclair Naomi J elgawa as
Yoko Tanaka and a laundry list of other
strong names Additionally the actress
behind the 1990s version of Wednesday
Adams Christina Ricci will appear on the
Netflix series though it's unknown who
she'll play when it comes to Uncle
Fester he is a part of the series but
the character's casting was at least in
initially being kept Under Wraps
the series is meant to be an offshoot of
The Adams Family Netflix describes it as
a sleuthing supernaturally infused
mystery that follows Wednesday as a
student at Nevermore Academy variety
says that the story will involve
Wednesday developing psychic powers and
attempting to control them in the
meantime the towns surrounding the
school is terrorized by an ongoing
Killing Spree this mystery appears to
involve events from the past and
apparently has a connection to her
parents Wednesday has to navigate all
this while navigating student life
complete with new relationships and the
idiosyncrasies of her fellow students we
have a feeling she's going to have a
harder time whipping her new classmates
in the shape than those Campers at Camp
Chippewa and Adams Family Values when
she staged a Revolt that eventually led
to the destruction of the camp on August
17 2022 Netflix gave Adams Family fans
what they've been waiting for the
Wednesday trailer despite clocking in at
just over two minutes long the teaser
did an excellent job of explaining what
the series is all about we see Wednesday
get in trouble at a school by letting
piranhas loose in a student-occupied
pool before we jump to her parents
shipping her off to Nevermore Academy we
get a look at some of the school's
Personnel students and the academy
itself as things really go off the rails
upon our arrival we find that
Wednesday's new school isn't all that
it's cracked up to be Wednesday narrates
in the trailer little did I know that
I'd be stepping into a nightmare full of
mystery Mayhem and murder
wow that might sound horrifying to the
average person Wednesday has a different
feeling I think I'm going to love it
here after a quick and appropriately
chaotic Montage the trailer ends with
Wednesday snapping her fingers twice an
incredibly appropriate homage to the
famous Addams Family theme song
Nevermore Academy was founded in 1791.
its sole Mission has been to celebrate
and nurture those who lie on the fringes
of society principal Weems Ponders an
interesting question in the trailer in a
world full of normies
do you feel like an outcast she adds
that she too has felt like an oddity and
invites the audience to learn more about
the academy and all that is in store
through a special video presentation the
academy offers a wide range of studies
including werewolf reproduction and
Gorgon Anatomy that's only the beginning
of the experience for the students that
pass the application process
extracurricular activities run the gamut
from painting to archery the academy
also boasts such notable alumni as
Gothic novelist Edgar Allan Poe and
ignacius it as well as Morticia and
Gomez Adams in the words of two of the
students The well-respected Institute is
open to students from all walks of life
and death
in a featurette released on August 24th
Ortega opens up about her strenuous
schedule preparing to play the show's
titular character worried about stepping
into the role's Legacy she took fencing
and cello lessons twice a week her
commitment extended into every facet of
the work including nailing down
Wednesday's physicality I would walk
like Wednesday and I think that people
thought I might have been kind of crazy
because I wanted her to be specific
certain and assertive director Tim
Burton even compared Ortega's approach
to that of a silent movie actress
because of her ability to convey her
thoughts without words he praised her
performance saying that he couldn't
imagine anyone else in the role while
previous iterations of the character
were cartoony in Burton's estimation a
sense of reality was brought to the
story to give Wednesday even more
grounded character elements Ortega also
notes that this Wednesday is much more
socially awkward than previous
iterations and her confidence is more
concealed compared to what fans may have
seen in the past
Christina Ricci forever immortalized
Wednesday in 90s films The Adams Family
and Adams Family Values while her role
in the forthcoming series remains top
secret she told collider that the role
is outrageous and different than
anything she'd ever done she also shared
that she especially enjoyed spending
time in a world where everybody seems so
thrilled to be doing the wrong thing for
Richie what makes Wednesday even more
special is the fact that Tim Burton
asked her directly to be involved she
said to be asked to be part of a new
version of this thing that is a huge
part of my identity and my history and
my life I was really touched by it while
Richie's Wednesday has a sharp intensity
to it Ortega's turn brings a different
energy one that Richie thinks is smart
timely and appropriate she also observes
that the breakout star possesses the
quote Spirit of dignity and self-respect
that Wednesdays so loved for for her
part Ortega commented how terrified she
was to be filming with Richie especially
when getting into the exact same costume
Richie wore 30 years ago she then
swapped compliments noting how Richie's
performance in the 90s films was
flawlessly done and Pitch Perfect adding
I wouldn't change anything about it
which is another reason it was hard for
me to do this job
[Music]